Rima Hassan, en 7e position sur la liste,
est-ce que ça a fait l'objet d'un débat ?
Non, au contraire, c'est 1 grande fierté pour nous.
Rima Hassan est 1 jury,
cet endroit international,
c'est 1 1 femme qui a 1 parcours extraordinaire,
assez singulier puisqu'elle a grandi,
elle, dans 1 camp de réfugiés palestiniens en Syrie
et elle porte
1 orientation,
1 proposition,
1 vigilance
par particulaire sur la question des camps de
réfugiés et sur le besoin,
la nécessité de construire 1 paix juste et
durable au prochain.
Et donc je pense que ça présente sur cette liste
dit aussi notre préoccupation et notre
revendication que,
notamment dans la campagne des élections européennes,
on fasse en sorte d'aller vers la paix.
Tapez tout simplement au Proche-Orient
qui dans 1 conflit qui a duré
malheureusement depuis bien trop longtemps.
Et je pense qu'elle portera avec nous cette aspiration.
J'en suis très fière et je suis reconnaissant
qu'elle ait accepté notre
proposition de figurer sur cette liste.